greets everyone I'm Ilana and today I'm
going to be attempting every single
female characters voice in overwatch
some of them are going to be very bad
we'll get through it
oh you look tired go to sleep
the pain is coming offense matrix
activated boosters engaged all right
game face on justice range from above I
will protect the innocent she is loved
the Cavalry's a boy this is no time for
standing around ever get that feeling of
deja vu everything can be hacked and
everyone initiating back I might need
this later oh that was not good freeze
don't move our world is worth fighting
for
it's good to get out of the lab I have
to get back in the fight
I will shape order from chaos defenses
in place shield generator online you are
protected blended ready for battle give
me another shot
hello monster try one shot one kill
I have you in my sights enough waiting
our hunger not a robot so this one's
tough fortifying defenses for your own
safety get behind the barrier your
safety is my primary concern I'll be
watching over you support has arrived a
speedy recovery [ __ ] I did my best you
guys if you want to see a video that's
worse than this one you know let me know
if you want to see me attempt to do the
men's voices hold up alrighty then you
guys so much for watching I will see
y'all next time bye